[Music]
all right in eggplant emoji news this
one comes from Angel City a recent study
shows that using emojis gets you laid
more often
mmm that's crazy right cuz remember like
maybe even five years ago if you used an
emoji it was like so unprofessional and
so like I've been considered a fair show
ah bah shot-by-shot
tries you but not so commonplace
everyone uses it oh yeah I use them
ironically it's fun mm-hmm I use them
ironically emojis it's a good way to say
something risky and then somebody
responds the way you don't want you but
like I was just kidding that's why I use
emojis like it leaves that door cracked
you like oh I was just playing I mean
every also like this one there's that
one yeah it's like you gotta be like
stop or some [ __ ] it's funny I love this
one and I don't like when guys use them
though really yeah a sexist I got a
little [ __ ] that's hella sexy that's
exactly what it is yes is that go it is
down really I've been five full full of
rice this is a tire time I've been
hearing geo feels as waves because of
tradition tradition tradition damn right
I know and then you're reinforcing it
song I don't get it sad to see up close
a recent study conducted by researchers
at the Kinsley Kinsey Institute in
Indiana found that frequent use of
emojis is directly linked to having more
sex or sex more frequently and the way
that they did it is so guys that text
with emoji or girls that text with these
so this is what they did they conducted
two separate surveys the first they
found that 20% of Americans use emojis
regularly three percent use one in every
text 2.5 percent use more than one in
every text and all participants found
that using emojis provided them with a
outlet for self-expression than
text-based messages so I made him
fornear the second survey found that 97%
of its partakers using emojis when
speaking to potential love interest and
showed that emoji use is related to
maintaining connections with a first
date meaning that people would be more
likely to engage in intimate behaviors
as the time progresses so because with
emojis like you're able to express more
than just through the words they're
saying that people that use more emojis
tend to like express more open
themselves up more for to potential love
interest and so their which they're just
better at communicators yeah that leads
to more sex or sex more frequent yeah
it's crazy because you say more with the
emoji by saying less by using emoji
yeah you just put the eggplant and
little water dripping by trying to get
too big it was like well like don't
forget to wash the eggplants I thought I
meant I wanna I wanna I thought it meant
that go on a nut somehow I mean that's
ooh oh you just need to cleanse and
vegetables yeah like we're gonna eat
veggies tonight so wash them are you
either way whether is that or this
ridiculous [ __ ] is said it says a lot by
just two emojis right so like I think my
thing is I don't wash my veggies what
yes you Tom I like real vegetables
because I cook them I don't know yeah I
know I don't use it loof oh of course
not he doesn't use something bacteria
all over your body have you seen the
Asian ones and what are you talking
about have you seen the Asian ones an
Asian drag it is
but it's like it's like a loofah but
it's flat can you show that towel yeah
Asian bathtub dude it's like wash you
know that [ __ ] that wire metal [ __ ]
that you used to scrub your dishes like
steel wool yeah steel wool it's like
that it's wrong it's sad paper roll like
yeah what are you an agent yeah really
you do your exfoliation you go to the
epidermis and then you chemical peel
yeah you can shave with this guy's yeah
I mean that's it those are gloves for
some reason but I mean that's all I
found set it's just not a glove you
could have it yeah it's made out of
plastic you can have it and you come out
like because you're just so red well
there's öhlins that I buy you don't you
don't do that every day then I would
imagine because you said well you say
you do it once I do it once a month back
I should probably you could probably do
it lightly every day I do it you do or
whatever I do are you having one in a
badass right there you go thank you
you could have handled that with an
emoji you didn't have to actually yeah
this was well they told us to put our
phone on airplane mode so no you
couldn't okay I'm sorry this is the one
that yeah that's the one I'll see y'all
be like [ __ ] sixties dude you know
what's crazy is like if you don't take a
shower with your partner you're back is
it clean I could look yeah but you can't
do the whole thing I can't all right
well I don't even try me neither
what's open back a handshake on the wall
with it you don't have a son
you don't have the back scrubber Oh cute
okay you could get one words like this
one just [ __ ] you like literally is what
do you get
that's good it's 11 bucks you have state
gas and a dirty bag oh Sid I everything
on your backside is next
I got a [ __ ] stamp yeah I mean you know
you do your pencils like bacterial
culture right now so you shampoo you got
head and shoulders all of your body of
course I use you sad you use shampoo
noise oh yeah chose the nasty one let me
tell you my technique yes
you know you know headed shoulders
mm-hmm one of my favorite shampoos by
the way squeeze that [ __ ] go I
put extra on right right and I have so
much soap I don't want to waste so I go
down to my face go out to my chest down
and then I finish but you know the heavy
so it doesn't cut grease the way regular
soap does it's not meant for skinny oh
it is regular soap below the ankle and
you see and his girl is set then he
smells like [ __ ] yeah well I mean I
don't know I'm maybe a little right on
my particular we can have it and then I
I did have better bathing habits and
then I don't have those products anymore
so I just said oh well this is faster
cuz the stores don't exist anymore your
neighborhood or I just don't Oregon all
these costumes but you can't get so I
don't Amazon the costumes anymore mister
me the linen him yeah that was years ago
sad that's I'm sorry one more costume I
want Peter Pan again oh I wasted so much
money you know how much money I [ __ ]
blew on just rags and then a costume is
not costing me like three thousand
dollars a pop you can afford fifty bucks
are you sure but I would love to see you
in a Captain Hook out
like that I spent thousands on weapons
and costumes and instruments in random
[ __ ] that piled up and I was like wow
why you what did you do it is that hero
has it it's all over they often I stab
boxes is it all over me yeah I always
look at the shoe I'm like who did you
take the wall and then I left one of my
shoes there cuz it got stuck cool yeah
yeah it's always cool to have new guests
in here and they're like what the [ __ ]
am i into I was throwing an axe at her
cuz she wanted to see if she could stop
it with the sword and then I think she
hit it and it blew all and then went
inside that wall at least I hit it I was
used to me yeah but now we're so like so
really tame now it's boring you know why
cuz I'm not spending money on bad things
anymore that's like yeah I've seen you
though so maybe you should start again
okay I'll start I'll start I'll chip
into your fund tell me where you're
going
favorite memory is is when we stab the
sword through the wall over there oh
yeah that's pretty good that's just a
different you guys are all frat boys I'm
just gonna go ahead and say it
everybody's ever Steve actually did our
asses though that's a frat boy [ __ ] yes
that's part of it but we did whittle
pray with the BB gun that was it me and
to here watching you guys do this [ __ ]
like that takes a lot of energy I'm good
absolutely here we're we're scientists
uh-huh we're not frat boys this is for
science excuse me I'm a woman yeah he's
our frat boy everyone everything
everything about him says frat boy to
t-shirt and every time he won her every
time I want to solve a problem he he
wants to beat the [ __ ] out of it have
you noticed that that's not a frat boy
that is that's not frat boy you want to
go broke he not go bro that's a hell of
frat boy all right
five miles for that settle but [ __ ]
frat boy McGee over here me up I didn't
know frat people but perhaps frat boys
don't fight they space they they stayed
talking ya know they fight though
where's the last time you got in a fight
over he never talks he just he's just
attacked I think every week it's part
week hmm no it's about like I like like
bar fight
oh because I would like to engage in
more so you are a frat boy Oh nobody a
little no he doesn't say well get my ass
beat every week by your trainer yeah cuz
he's really good cuz he's paid to beat
your ass yes
the moment you start beating your
trainers asses the moment he's no longer
your trainer should be fired right yeah
yeah that's a good point
[ __ ] frat boy dude I pointed that out
to them before cuz their coach got his
ass beat in an MMA match and they didn't
fire him on the spot what I know I was
like that's like getting robbed what is
the category you would you say your
coach got beat in an MMA fight and I
said you guys should fire him and hire
the other guy and you guys wouldn't do
it he won the next fight up then that's
too funny I didn't know that oh hey
lucky punch
and he's my good friend now I'm a loan
from forever okay fine but if he loses
too many times in a row yeah they're all
that for them secretly cuz you don't
want to get better do you is it about
image or do you want to get better I
like meeting friendships okay it's about
image I can't believe I don't stab walls
anymore what happened to me
[Music]